and so much is changing that to my
marriage kids divorce people have been
through it all I mean skies I started
the show when I was in nineteen I'm 34
now I feel so old but even like so back
then it was more about being single
going out with our friends having fun
originally it started with four girls
and it was us being friends and going
out living in LA and then the guys got
involved and the jarama started and then
it was about dating and back and forth
now you know cut to 10 15 years later
and four moms were you know parents
going through divorces and life has
changed but you know it's also finding
the balance of being a mother or parents
dating and work life owning your own
business so but also going out there
there's lots of drama between our
friends our group of friends was it an
easy decision for you to come back or
did you sort of go back and forth I mean
I was kind of excited at first and I was
like we I really need to like think
about this and not opposed to it but I
was like I have a daughter now the hill
is like my life is nothing what it was
10 to 15 years ago so how am I going to
film because I feel like my life is so
boring now you know it's not I don't go
out I'm a mom and that's my priority and
my daughter's not really on the show so
no one will see that but I do talk about
it for me it's more of my life building
with this version of my life with this
group of friends coming up to LA and
just resolving unresolved issues and
like being a part of me shows that that
was a big part of it actually that a lot
of the issues between the cast members
are still unresolved I mean there's so
much history with us all from like the
pad
fifteen years so a lot of that is still
not even resolved so if we get a second
season and hopefully they'll become
resolved do you have you spoken to
Lauren has she sort of given the show
its blessing no none of us have spoken
to her I mean I think Frankie's the only
wine had no idea Justin single now and
you're single is there any chance that
you guys will rekindle a friendship
romance say that but we're still filming
so we'll we'll have to see what what's
your most memorable experience from the
original series I mean cover of Rolling
Stone after-show and always said the
cover of Rolling Stone magazine like
that was the most like iconic and
eye-opening experience that I was like
oh my god because you know it's so
surreal and I'm such in my own bubble
that I don't block a lot of it out
that's such a normal life yeah that was
it the cover of Rolling Stones when you
look back is there anything that you
would have done differently on the first
season or first you know
no actually no I mean I probably would
have said oh no a lot more but I think I
have no regrets and I am Who I am today
because what I wanted through so
everyone's been really yeah
you